The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ALAN V. OPPENHEIM: During
the last three lectures,
we considered the design of
infinite impulse response
digital filters.
The two main classes of design
procedures that we discussed
involved mapping
continuous time designs
to discrete time designs.
That was the first class.
And the second class was the
use of algorithmic design
procedures.
In this lecture, I
would like to discuss
the design of finite impulse
response digital filters.
And I remind you that
as we've stressed
in a number of the lectures, one
of the very important aspects
of finite impulse
response digital filters
is the fact that they
can be implemented
to have exactly linear phase.
So finite impulse
response filters,
as opposed to infinite
impulse response filters,
are useful for problems
where linear phase is
an important constraint.
It turns out also--
and this isn't a point
that we'll be touching on
in these lectures--
but it turns out also that
finite impulse response
digital filters have
some important advantages
over infinite impulse
response filters
with regard to round
off noise, that is,
with regard to the effects
of finite register length.
Now in general,
the implementation
of finite impulse
response filters
is considerably simpler
for discrete time systems
than it is for
continuous time systems.
Consequently, it turns out that
there are not really available,
or a wide variety of continuous
time design procedures
for finite impulse
response filters
as there were for
infinite impulse response.
And consequently, the continuous
time to discrete time mapping,
as a design procedure,
is not particularly
applicable to the design
of finite impulse response
digital filters.
So this includes, for example,
the impulse and variant
technique, and the use of
the bilinear transformation.
That is, those techniques
are not particularly useful
when we are talking about
the design of finite impulse
response filters.
As an additional
interesting side point,
if we were to begin with
a finite impulse response
analog or continuous
time filter,
and map it to a digital
filter using the bilinear
transformation, then in
fact the resulting filter
would not be a finite
impulse response filter.
The algorithmic
procedures that we
talked about in the previous
lectures, of course, still
do apply to the design of
finite impulse response filters.
And there also are some
other algorithmic procedures
that are discussed in
the text, and that I
will touch on just very
briefly in today's lecture.
Now for the design of finite
impulse response filters,
there are basically
three classes,
or three types of
design techniques
that we'll be discussing.
And in this lecture,
what I intend to do
is present the three
of these, primarily
with an eye toward giving
you an appreciation for what
the style of the
design techniques is.
That is, to give you an overview
of these design techniques.
But I won't dwell on
many of the details.
So in the design of
finite impulse response
digital filters,
then, we of course
are talking about a
unit sample response
that is a finite length.
And we'll choose the length,
the interval over which the unit
sample response is non-zero
to be in the range from 0
to capital N minus 1.
So the Z-transform of the
finite impulse response filter
is then given by the sum from 0
to capital N minus 1 of h of n,
z to the minus n, which of
course is a polynomial in z
to the minus 1.
And we know that, for this
class of systems, h of z
has only zeros,
except at z equal 0.
That is, the poles of h of z
can only fall at z equals 0,
or z equals infinity.
And I remind you also that for
linear phase finite impulse
response filters, the constraint
on the unit sample response
is that it basically is
symmetrical about its midpoint.
In other words, as we
look at the unit sample
response starting
from the left hand end
and starting from
the right hand end,
approaching toward the middle,
then we see the same values.
In other words, there's
a symmetry that's
required for linear phase.
The three basic
design procedures
that I'd like to talk
about in this lecture,
basically introduce
in the lecture,
are first of all,
a design technique
which is referred to
as the window method.
The second design
technique that is commonly
referred to as the
frequency sampling method.
And a third designed technique,
which is an algorithmic design
procedure which results in
equiripple filters, which
as I'll comment on
again when we get
to this point in the
lecture, turn out
to be important
because they have
some optimality properties.
So these are the three basic
design techniques, then,
that I'd like to
discuss in this lecture.
Well, to begin with,
the window method
is basically a method based
on the following strategy.
Let's suppose that we begin the
design of the finite impulse
response filter with a desired
unit sample response, h sub
d of n.
For example, suppose
that we wanted
to design a low pass filter.
We could begin with
a desired unit sample
response which was the
unit sample response
of an ideal low pass filter.
Now as you know, the unit sample
response of an ideal low pass
filter basically has a sin
x over x type of envelope.
In particular, the
important characteristic
is that it extends from minus
infinity to plus infinity.
So in fact, it doesn't
correspond to a finite impulse
response filter.
But we could imagine
obtaining the unit sample
response of an FIR filter
by perhaps truncating
this infinitely long unit sample
response so that we retain
only the values in the interval
from 0 to capital N minus 1.
Or more generally, we can
imagine multiplying the desired
unit sample response by a
window, the window being
0 outside the interval from
0 to capital N minus 1.
So the window method
basically consists
of beginning with a desired
unit sample response, which
in general will be
infinitely long,
or at least longer than the
filter that we want to design.
We apply to that a window,
which is 0 outside the range 0
to capital N minus 1.
And the result then is
the unit sample response
of the finite impulse
response filter.
Well, what is the effect of
this in the frequency domain?
We know that multiplication
in the time domain
corresponds to convolution
in the frequency domain.
And consequently, the frequency
response of the finite impulse
response filter that results,
is the periodic convolution
of the desired
frequency response.
That is, the Fourier transform
of the desired unit sample
response, that convolved
with the Fourier
transform of the window, w of n
For example, if we were talking
about a rectangular window,
and in a rectangular
window, w of n
is simply constant over the
range 0 to capital N minus 1,
the magnitude of the Fourier
transform of the window
has a form roughly as
I've indicated here.
This is drawn for
the case, N equals 8.
And it's the magnitude of
h of e to the j omega--
I'm sorry, of w of
e to the j omega.
If we were to remove
the magnitude sines,
then every alternate lobe
would be flipped over in sine.
So in fact, this is a
sin nx over sin x curve.
So for the particular case
of a rectangular window,
we would have not the ideal low
pass filter that we began with,
but the ideal lowpass filter
frequency characteristic
convolved with the Fourier
transform of the window.
So that's depicted here where we
have the ideal low pass filter.
Superimposed on top of it
is the Fourier transform
of, in this case, a
rectangular window.
And then to obtain the
resulting overall frequency
response of the finite
impulse response filter,
that would be obtained by
convolving these two together.
And we can see that the
result of that, very roughly,
is to, in fact, at
the discontinuity,
the almost exact effect is to
integrate the window frequency
response, the frequency
response of the window.
And the resulting frequency
response for the finite impulse
response filter then,
as opposed to being
the ideal characteristic
that we desired, in fact
has some ripples in it.
Generally, then, it has some
deviation in the pass band.
It has some deviation
in the stop band.
And it has a transition region
from pass band to stop band.
And that's introduced because of
the convolution of this window
frequency response with the
desired or ideal frequency
response.
Now ideally, what would
we like as the frequency
response of the window?
Well, ideally what we
would like, of course,
is we would like this
function to be an impulse.
Because if it's an
impulse, then we
convolve it with the
desired frequency response,
and the result will again be
the desired frequency response.
The overshoot that we have in
the pass band and the stop band
has arisen because of the side
lobe structure of the frequency
response of the window.
And the transition region
has arisen because,
primarily because of the
width of this central lobe.
So, in fact, if we want to keep
the deviation in the pass band
and stop band small,
then that implies
that we would like
to keep the side lobe
structure of the window
small, the window frequency
response small.
And if we would like to keep
the transition band narrow,
that implies that we would like
to keep this main lobe narrow.
And as I think that
your intuition should
agree with by now,
generally, an attempt
to make this function
narrower in frequency
will have the general
effect of making
the window longer in time.
So that, in fact, as we try to
make the time window, w of n,
or equivalently, the order of
the finite impulse response
filter smaller,
the tendency will
be toward a widening transition
band in the frequency
response of the filter.
Likewise, as we allow the order
of the filter to get longer,
we have more flexibility
in the filter.
And consequently, we're able to
control better the transition
band and the overshoot
in both the pass band
and in the stop band.
Well, in particular,
again continuing
with the example of
a rectangular window,
if we look at the
frequency-- the unit sample
response for the case
of an ideal low pass
filter multiplied by a 51
point rectangular window,
then the unit sample response
we obtain is as indicated here.
Actually, I've marked this
as the desired unit sample
response.
It's only equal to the
desired unit sample response
in the interval from 0 to 50.
And the desired unit
sample response, of course,
continues to be non-zero
outside that range.
Whereas multiplying by
a rectangular window
truncates it to be 0
outside this range.
The resulting frequency response
for this particular example
I've indicated here.
And as opposed to the
previous frequency response
that I depicted, this is shown
on a logarithmic frequency
scale.
There, in fact, is some
ripple in the pass band,
although it's not evident on
a logarithmic frequency scale.
But generally, you can see the
effect of a transition band,
and then a side lobe
structure in the stop band.
And you can see also that the
asymptotic behavior of this
is--
in the vicinity for this
particular example--
is in the vicinity of minus
20 dB attenuation in the stop
band.
So this then is an example
of a low pass filter that
could be obtained by
applying a rectangular window
to the ideal low pass filter.
There are other possible
choices for windows.
In particular, two other
choices that I'd like to mention
are what are referred
to as the Hamming window
and the Bartlett window.
As opposed to the
rectangular window,
the Bartlett window is
a triangular window,
which has the effect
basically of making
the transition at the ends
of the unit sample response
less abrupt than they are in the
case of a rectangular window.
The Hamming window is a window
which corresponds essentially
to a cosine bell sitting
on a small pedestal.
So for this particular example,
again, the low pass filter,
the ideal low pass
filter windowed,
we can compare the
frequency response obtained
with the Bartlett
window to that obtained
with the rectangular window, and
also with the Hamming window.
So let's take a look at that.
Here we have the
frequency response
of the Bartlett window.
And you can see generally
that the ripples aren't
as severe in the
stop band as they
were in the case of
the rectangular window.
And in fact, we can
compare these simply
by referring back to the
rectangular window frequency
response that we had previously.
So the rectangular window lies
slightly under, or actually
asymptotically touches the
frequency response obtained
from the Bartlett window.
But for the Bartlett window,
the ripples in the stop band
aren't as severe as they are
for the rectangular window.
Now to compare both of
these to the Hamming window,
we can put on top of this
the frequency response
for the Hamming window.
And in this case, you can see
that the frequency response
obtained with the Hamming window
applied to a low pass filter
has considerably better
stop band attenuation
than either the rectangular
or the Bartlett window.
In particular, it comes down
to about minus 30 or minus 32
or so dB.
There is a slight
price paid for this.
And the price is, as you
notice, that the transition band
is slightly wider than it is
for either of the other two
windows.
And in general, this
is a type of trade off
that arises again and again
in the design of-- actually,
always in the design of
digital or analog filters.
In particular, in
using windows, there
is always this trade off between
improved stop band attenuation
and a narrower-- or wider,
rather-- transition band.
As you are willing to
allow the transition
band to become wider,
you can generally
obtain some advantage in terms
of stop band attenuation.
All right.
So this is a quick view
into the use of windows.
In the text, in fact, there
are quite a large number
of windows that are discussed,
besides the rectangular,
the Bartlett, and
the Hamming window.
And similar frequency
responses for filters
designed using a
variety of these windows
is presented in the text.
The next design procedure
that I would like to discuss
is the design procedure that
is referred to as the frequency
sampling design procedure.
And basically, the idea
behind that procedure
is to argue that if we
have a desired frequency
response, which I've indicated
by the continuous line--
a desired frequency response--
then we could think of
designing a digital filter
by specifying samples
of the desired frequency
response at equally spaced
points along the frequency
axis.
Now we know that for a
finite impulse response
digital filter--
in general, for any
finite length sequence--
we can represent it in terms
of samples of its Fourier
transform.
That, in fact, is the
discrete Fourier transform.
So basically what
we're saying is
that we can begin with a
desired frequency response
and specify the discrete Fourier
transform of the finite impulse
response filter by specifying
equally spaced samples
of the desired
frequency response.
So we have then that the
actual frequency response
will correspond to
capital N samples, equally
spaced in frequency, of the
desired frequency response
characteristic.
Now one could say that, or one
could inquire as to whether,
in fact, if we do that,
what we're able to implement
is the desired digital
filter frequency response.
In other words, we know that we
can implement a finite impulse
response filter by using
only the values specified
in the discrete
Fourier transform.
And here we've specified a
discrete Fourier transform
that's unity in the pass band
and it's zero in the stop band.
And one can ask,
well, in fact, is
that an ideal digital
low pass filter?
Well, the answer to that is no.
And the reason is that it
is important, very important
to keep track of the fact
that just because we specify
the frequency response
at equally spaced points
along the frequency
axis doesn't mean
that, in between those
points, the frequency
characteristic has to be
particularly well-behaved.
That is, the Fourier transform
of the unit sample response
is a continuous
function of frequency.
We're specifying samples
of that continuous function
of frequency.
And there is implied
an interpolation
in between those samples.
Well, in fact, if we were
to look at a unit sample
response whose discrete Fourier
transform magnitude is unity
in the pass band and
zero in the stop band,
one possible choice, in fact,
is the unit sample response
and frequency response
that I've indicated here.
This is the unit
sample response.
This is the corresponding
frequency response.
The discrete Fourier
transform of h of n, in fact,
is exactly unity in the pass
band and zero in the stop band.
But the interpolation
in between those points
is not unity in the pass band
and zero in the stop band.
In fact, by simply putting
the previous view graph
on top of this one, we can see
that this frequency response
characteristic indeed goes
through the specified frequency
points.
But it is not particularly
well constrained
in between those points.
So, in fact, for one
example, if we chose this
as the unit sample
response corresponding
to this set of
frequency samples,
the resulting frequency response
of the finite impulse response
low pass filter would
be as we've indicated
with this continuous curve.
Well, we know that there
are other unit sample
responses whose discrete
Fourier transforms are
exactly the same.
The magnitude of the
discrete Fourier transform
is exactly the same as this one.
In particular, we know that if
we were to circularly rotate
h of n, circularly shift
h of n, the magnitude
of the discrete
Fourier transform
would remain exactly the same.
So in fact, another
unit sample response
that would correspond to a
frequency response, which
likewise goes through the
same frequency samples,
is the one that we have here.
This unit sample response
is simply the previous one,
circularly shifted by
approximately n over 2,
or n minus 1 over 2.
And in this case, the frequency
response characteristic
is even worse than it was
in the previous example.
So here we have a
frequency response
that has very wild, large
fluctuations in the pass band,
and even in the stop
band, but still goes
through the same
frequency samples
that we had
specified previously.
And we can see that
by, again, putting
these two on top of each other.
And you can see,
in this case again,
that this frequency
characteristic
goes through the specified
frequency samples.
But it has a very wild
behavior in between.
All right.
So the frequency sampling
method, then, is basically
a method that consists
of specifying samples
of the frequency
response, and then
accepting the interpolation
in between those samples
that is dictated by the form
of the unit sample response.
And I stress that one has to
be careful in the phase that's
applied to this,
or equivalently,
the circular shift that's
applied to the unit sample
response, since as we've
seen in the last several view
graphs, that very
seriously affects
the interpolation in between
these frequency points.
Furthermore, an additional
point has been made,
and that is that it is not--
even though we can implement
a finite impulse
response filter using
the discrete Fourier transform,
specifying the discrete Fourier
transform to be unity
in the pass band
and zero in the
stop band does not
mean that we've implemented
an ideal low pass filter.
All right.
Well, we had-- this, of
course, is not a unit sample
response that we would be
particularly anxious to use.
Clearly, the behavior in
the pass band and stop band
is very severe, and
in fact, too severe.
So we could at least consider
as somewhat reasonable
the unit sample
response and frequency
response that we had
previously, in this case,
relatively well-behaved.
That is, it ripples
somewhat in the pass band
and in the stop band.
But now we could inquire
as to whether there
is some way of improving the
pass band ripple and the stop
band ripple.
We know, or we anticipate,
that there's a price that we
would have to pay for that.
Probably the price,
and indeed it
turns out that the
price we have to pay
is the price of widening
the transition band.
Well, how could we widen
the transition band?
We could imagine beginning
with this particular design,
taking as one possibility one
of the stop band constrained
points.
And allow it to move
into the transition band
so that, in fact, we
have a wider frequency
range that we're permitting
the transition from pass band
to stop band to go to.
And let me illustrate that
here, where now what we've done
is to take one of the frequency
samples in the stop band,
move it up into the
transition band.
And as we do that, you can see
for this particular example,
the pass band ripple
hasn't changed too much.
But in fact, the
stop band ripple
has changed somewhat
dramatically.
As we allow this transition
point to move farther up
into the transition
band, basically widening
the general pass band
region, what we'll see
is that the pass band ripple
become somewhat smaller.
And there, in fact,
is a trade off
that is introduced between the
pass band ripple and the stop
band ripple.
And let me illustrate that
with this next example, where
in this case, we have moved the
transition point up somewhat
further.
So that whereas in
the previous case
the transition point
was someplace down here,
we've now moved it farther up
into the transition region,
closer to the pass band.
And the pass band ripple has
become correspondingly smaller.
So this, in fact, is
a design technique
that can be used for the design
of, generally, band frequency
selective filters, where
we first of all specify
frequency samples.
In fact, this can
be used, really,
for the design of any
digital filter characteristic
with transition regions.
And then, perhaps, [AUDIO OUT]
reducing the ripple in the pass
band and/or the stop band,
or in the various bands,
by allowing an additional
point to be used
to widen the transition band.
And as we move this
point up or down,
then, we will reduce the pass
band and the stop band ripple.
We can also, of course, consider
moving not just one point
into the transition region,
but two points or three
points or more points.
Obviously, as we do that, we
will widen the transition band
further.
And at the same
time, that offers
some additional
flexibility, which
permits us to reduce the pass
band and stop band ripple.
So this then is
basically the strategy
in the frequency sampling
method of digital filter design.
The final method
that I would like
to touch on just very
briefly is a method
which I referred to at the
beginning of this lecture
as an equiripple design method.
And basically,
the notion here is
that we've seen that
there is a trade off
between the transition
region on the one hand,
and pass band and stop band
ripple on the other hand.
Well, one could inquire
as to whether, in at least
in some sense, we could
design for ourselves
an optimum class of filters.
And indeed, you can.
And in fact, it's
possible to show
that the optimum strategy in
terms of minimizing pass band
or stop band ripple, or in
terms of minimizing a transition
band, is to design the filter
to have an equiripple frequency
response characteristic.
Well, one way of setting up
the optimal condition-- and it
turns out that there
are a variety of ways,
and these are discussed in quite
a bit more detail in the text.
But for example, if we
pick a pass band cutoff
frequency and a stop
band cutoff frequency.
Furthermore, if
we, of course, are
going to allow some
deviation in the pass band
and some deviation in the
stop band, if in addition,
we fix the ratio of stop
band to pass band ripple,
and if we then inquire as to
what sort of characteristic
should result if
delta 1, the pass band
ripple, or
equivalently, delta 2,
the stop band ripple
is minimized--
this should be delta 2--
so if delta 1 and
delta 2 are minimized,
it turns out it can be
shown that that implies
an equiripple characteristic
in the pass band,
and an equiripple
characteristic in the stop band.
That is, the ripples
in the pass band
should alternate between
the upper and lower limits.
And the ripples in
a stop band should
alternate between the
upper and lower limits.
In the text, there are discussed
several algorithmic procedures
for actually designing
equiripple filters.
We won't go through those
details in this lecture.
Mainly, I want to
emphasize the point
that there are procedures that
allow you to implement designs
of this type.
And that designs of
this type are optimum.
Let me just show you one example
of an optimum equiripple finite
impulse response filter that
was designed when our computer
budget was particularly big.
This is an example of a length
251 point finite impulse
response digital
filter, designed
using one of the algorithms
that is discussed in the text.
And you can see that, indeed,
the equiripple characteristics
are evident in the pass band.
This curve corresponds to
the frequency characteristics
plotted in dB.
So the pass band
ripple doesn't show up.
So with that scale expanded,
we can see the ripple.
And then we have the
ripple in the stop band.
There should be 125
ripples all together.
And in fact, we could
see if that was true.
We could [AUDIO OUT]
one, two, three.
But let's not do that.
Obviously, there's a very
sharp transition band.
And what turns out to be
minus approximately 80--
approximately minus 85 dB
attenuation in the stop band.
So this is an example of a very
high order equiripple optimum
finite impulse response
digital filter that
was designed using one of
the algorithms discussed
in the text.
OK.
Well, this, as I indicated at
the beginning of the lecture,
was intended primarily
as a very brief overview
of finite impulse response
digital filter design.
Hopefully, it gives
you some appreciation
for the style of the
design techniques.
There are, of course, a
large number of details,
some of which are discussed
in the text and some of which
aren't.
But in any case, this, then,
concludes our discussion
of the design of
infinite impulse response
and finite impulse
response digital filters.
In the next lecture, we will
begin a new topic, specifically
the topic involving
the computation
of the discrete
Fourier transform.
Thank you.